next up twitter is testing up voting and
down voting buttons for some ios users
this
is brilliant i love this idea the goal
of the buttons is to highlight
the more interesting and relevant
replies in long threads
this would be great because you don't
really have a way to signal i disagree
with this or i find this quote lame in
some way
so a tweet from twitter support
yesterday
read some of you on ios may see
different options to up
or down vote on replies we're testing
this to understand the type of replies
you find relevant in a conversation
so we can work on ways to show more of
them your down votes are in public while
your upvotes
will be shown as likes in other words
they're taking what dig
and reddit pioneered and they're moving
that to twitter
this is great for threads because if you
go to reddit
or other forums you used to be able to
see the top
two or three threads up top now this
does change the chronological nature of
it
so you think of every child to the
parent tweet so i read a tweet
i thought that the tv series loki was
awesome and then 10 people reply
well one of those might be the most
interesting thread but it could be the
10th one down
it would be better to move that to the
top but it is going to take
a lot of retraining of users to
understand that because when you go to
reddit
you're like wait why is this child to
the parent tweet or the child thread why
is it up top oh it's up top because it's
the most interesting one
i kind of like that the buttons can be
seen as arrows
like reddits or thumbs like facebook so
they're testing a couple of different
versions of this
and there's only a small number of
testers can see these options but this
is the great
renaissance going on at twitter where
they're trying a bunch of different
things
and maybe not being so precious about uh
the product
some keynotes about the experiment
twitter support continued
this is just a test for research right
now this is not a dislike button
your downvotes are visible to you only
votes won't change the order of reply so
they're not doing the order replies yet
but that will be eventually where this
goes in
long threads um some responses from
twitter
with the obvious ones what's the point
of a dislike button if you can't see the
numbers
for it and then this isn't quite a
dislike button was the reply
in this research experiment the thumbs
down icon is a down vote
that lets us know that you think the
reply isn't relevant to the conversation
we want to better understand the types
of replies you do and don't find
relevant in a conversation
and cody elam uh hopefully i'm
pronouncing your last name correct cody
a user researcher at twitter tweeted
we're testing a few approaches to allow
people to upvote and downvote replies
this gives people the power to privately
voice their opinion on the quality of
replies without publicly shaming others
while giving us more nuanced feedback so
i think we you need to think about this
as they're just trying to get some
feedback on long threads
and i think whose opinions are quality
discussions
they're not trying to make this a
political one where it's like i disagree
with you
it's more this is an interesting reply
this is a less interesting reply
perhaps maybe thoughtful would be a way
to think of it this is a thoughtful
reply or a compelling reply
not that you disagree but that you find
it compelling or not compelling
and that's why at the bottom of reddit
threads or i think even hacker news
you'll see
like things that are voted down a whole
bunch i think on hacker news they made
them gray so that
you'd barely see them on the screen when
they get to the negative area
um so historically uh we've seen twitter
try and test other engagement buttons in
the
past uh and they've been serving
surveying users about emoji reactions
which is something you see on facebook
where you can put emoji reactions which
facebook stole from davemorin
and path.com and i think dave morin from
path.com got the idea
from some korean social networks if i my
internet history and my social media
history
is correct uh this this fits into a lot
of what uh
kavon uh bakepor discussed with me on
episode 1225 if you go back to episode
1225 i had uh the chief product had uh
at twitter on the program and twitter
wants to connect people to their
interests
and to conversations that are healthy so
they understand twitter's toxic i
am taking a twitter break not really for
the toxicity but more
to focus on this show because i realized
i was
doing all these tweets about things that
i talk about in the show and i'm just
like you know what i want to focus just
on the show
just on getting this podcast this week
in startups to four or five days a week
and really work on my performance here
and the information i share here
that's my goal that's why i'm taking a
bit of a twitter break i still look at
twitter every day
i'm probably spending less than half the
amount of time on twitter maybe a third
of the amount of time because i don't
reply anymore the only thing i'm doing
is i will uh like and retweet things
about the show so you know the new
episodes up
and i'm posting whenever the new show
comes out what's on the show today so i
just say newpod
and that's my plan for twitter and then
i'm going to spend the rest of the year
working on the book
and this podcast because i find these
those two platforms more interesting for
me
and i just have a limited amount of time
uh and as we wrap alexis ohanian
co-founder of reddit chimed in you
haven't really created a product until
someone else copies it
um yeah um it is you know imitation is a
sincerest form of flattery
um okay and finally in the uae drones
are zapping clouds with electricity
to create rain one of the driest
countries on earth the uae
has been hit hard by heat waves and
temperatures of up to 122 degrees and
according to the national center of
meteor
meteorology's website water security
remains one of uae's
main future challenges so right now the
country relies on groundwater for two
those of its water needs
this has made the country turn to create
rain artificially
uh called cloud seeding you've heard of
that before i'm sure
uh previously cloud seeding involved
salt flares where planes dropped a bunch
of flares into
low clouds but this is kind of different
the ua oversaw more than 200 cloud
seeding operations in the first half of
2020
successfully creating rainfall so here
we go
uh there have also been successes in the
us china india and thailand i wonder why
we're not doing this
when we have fires and we have wildfires
in california why aren't we going up and
seating the clouds and
creating rain and trying to put them out
a 10-year cloud
uh seating experiment in wyoming
resulted in five to ten
percent increases in snow packs this is
really interesting tahoe here
in california the real estate crashed
after we had like three or four
really bad short ski seasons because
there was no snow this could change
everything if we can
dump snow they might say you know what
this weekend there will be
four to seven inches of new powder and
we're going to
force that to happen or we're going to
intervene if it doesn't happen naturally
it's a brave new world folks obviously
there are concerns uh about the impact
on the environment
and the cost of doing this so this is
just testing out new
technology that zap clouds with
electricity create rain basically the
clouds are
clumped together and produce
precipitation artificially
the ua is one of the first countries in
the arab gulf region to use cloud
seeding technology
um and the efforts are part of the
country's ongoing
in quotes quest to ensure water security
since the 1990s through
the ua research program for rain
enhancement
teams today need a central hub for all
the information and work
that they're sharing especially now
because you're working remotely and
notion
allows you to take all of the talking
culture you had
and turn your company into a writing
culture company
you want to write stuff down and then
you want people to read it
comment on it and refine it and all that
knowledge builds and builds
inside your notion when we went fully
remote in march of 2020
notion became our internal knowledge
bank
and actually here is one of my producers
going through our pod notes page on
notion where we highlight all the top
lessons from every episode notion is the
one place
where every team from engineering to
sales can work together seamlessly
with 500 integrated apps including
google and slack
so you can collaborate in real time and
tailor workflows to your needs
hundreds of thousands of teams worldwide
are already delighting their employees
with notion plus notion has a worldwide
community
of millions of users creating templates
and tutorials so the product is
continually
improving go to notion.so and use the
promo code twist
to get 250 off your annual team
plan that's multiple months for
free for your growing team that's
notion.so and use the promo code twist
during checkout to get 250 very generous
software thank you to my friends at
notion
number one for making a great product
number two for 250 dollars
really good job